[PLAYING MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Thank you.
Thank you.
This next song that I'd like
to perform for you is-- you
know, one of the cool things
about playing the ukulele is
that you have a very
limited range.
And you have just basically
four strings to work with.
And I kind of talked about this
the last time I was here.
I said that you only
have four strings.
And sometimes, it can appear
to be very limiting.
Because you think, oh,
on the ukulele, I
only have four strings.
But on the guitar, a guitar has
six strings and you can
get a much fuller sound
and a bigger sound.
And you always want more and
more and more and more.
So I wrote this song recently.
Because I've been trying
to compose more.
And I always try to come up
with a concept or an idea,
whenever I'm writing
a new piece.
So this idea, though, came
about by accident.
See, I was changing my ukulele
strings one day.
And I put the first string on.
[PLUCKS STRING]
And then I put the
second string on.
[PLUCKS STRING]
And then, I was going to put
the third string on, but I
couldn't find that string.
So I was like, where did
I put my third string?
So I grabbed the
fourth string.
I put the fourth string on.
[PLUCKS STRING]
And instead of rushing off to
look for another third string,
I thought to myself, wouldn't
it be cool to write a song
with just three strings?
So this is a song called
"Missing Three."
And it's a piece that just
uses three strings.
That's it.
And I thought it was
kind of cool.
Because on the ukulele,
you always want more.
You always think you
need more strings.
You need a greater range.
So this is a song called
"Missing Three" that kind of
proves that you don't
always need more.
Sometimes less truly is more.
And if you know what you're
going for, if you know what
you want to say or what you're
trying to communicate, then
sometimes you can just
do it with three
strings, rather than four.
So here's a song called
"Missing Three."
[MUSIC - JAKE SHIMABUKURO,
"MISSING THREE"]
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Thank
you very much.
Thank you.
A song entitled "Missing
Three."
A couple other things happened
to me since the
last time I was here.
Shortly after I was here at
Google, I got married.
So that was pretty cool.
And seven weeks ago, my wife
and I had our first baby.
I know, I'm a dad.
That's kind of a scary
thought, right?
But it's the most
amazing thing.
Because I'm kind of at that age
where a lot of my friends
have children.
And a lot of them, they're on
their second child already.
But I remember when they first
had their baby, they would
always send me photos.
Or they on their phones, they'd
show me pictures.
And then I'm just like,
oh yeah, cute.
But on the inside I'm like,
I don't want to see this.
Why are you showing me this?
But it's amazing.
It's so different when
it's your own child.
When it's your own child, you're
just like, oh my god.
Every little thing that they
do, it's the cutest, most
adorable thing.
And it's so funny because
now, I'll
send pictures to everyone.
But it's really the most
amazing thing.
And so this next song,
I wrote it actually--
maybe when my wife was about
six months pregnant.
I wrote this song
for the baby.
And it's a song I call
"Gentlemandolin." And like I
was explaining before, that when
I write a piece, I always
like to have some concept,
something that is different
from anything else that I've
done before in the past.
And the way this song came about
was, I love the sound of
the mandolin.
The mandolin is actually
tuned like a violin.
So it has a wide range.
It has over a three-octave
range, whereas the ukulele
only has a two-octave range.
So you can get these beautiful,
lush chords on the
mandolin that are
very difficult
to get on the ukulele.
So I came across this chord
voicing that to me, in my
mind, kind of mimics the voicing
of a mandolin player.
And it sounds like this.
It's a really far stretch
like this, but you get
this kind of sound.
[STRUMMING CHORDS]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: It doesn't
sound like a ukulele.
It sounds more like
a mandolin.
So I wrote this song.
And I used that idea for
this tune for my son.
And I call it "Gentlemandolin."
And the
title came about because I was
thinking that I hope one day
when my son grows up, he'll
grow up to be a fine
gentleman--
dolin.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Here we go.
All right, it's cheesy.
I know.
All right.
Here we go.
[MUSIC - JAKE SHIMABUKURO,
"GENTLEMANDOLIN"]
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Thank
you very much.
Man.
I get my inspiration from
a lot of things.
I'm sure it's the same
for all of you.
All of you here, you're
all artists.
And you're always trying to
think of the next thing and
what's going to be that
next big idea.
And it's funny because sometimes
I get a lot of my
inspiration from the most
unusual things.
I just did a short interview
out here for that video.
I think it's called
"My Favorite
Things." What's it's called?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: "My Favorite
Things." So one of the things
that I talked about was one of
my favorite performances ever
was a performance
of Bill Cosby.
Bill Cosby, a long time ago, he
did this HBO special, this
stand-up comedy special, called
"Bill Cosby, Himself."
And it was the most--
I think till this day, of all
the comedians out there, this
performance is still like the
bible of stand-up comedy.
And if you haven't seen
it, you really
should check it out.
You guys have it in
your archive.
So you should definitely
check it out.
But if you can get the actual
DVD of the entire performance,
it is truly amazing.
It's almost two hours long.
And Bill Cosby sits
in a chair.
Not even a high chair,
a regular--
like a chair that you're
sitting in.
And he's just sitting in that
chair, holding a microphone,
and telling these stories.
And everyone is just at the
edge of their seats, just
dying, laughing,
so entertained.
And I realized-- because see,
for me, that was very
significant.
Because when I first started out
playing the ukulele, I was
always playing with a singer.
There was always a singer.
And then I would be in
the back playing--
[PLAYING CHORDS]
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: I would
be the backing guy.
So I'd be in the back,
just kind of playing.
And then when they're done
singing, then I'd take a
little solo.
[PLAYING MELODY]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: And
then back to--
[STRUMMING CHORDS]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: --and then
they're singing again.
So that was kind of my job.
And the reason for
that is because I
am a terrible singer.
I can't sing to save my life.
So after a while, when I stopped
working with singers,
I thought--
I had this little band
in high school.
And when we broke up, I thought,
oh, no, that's the
end for me.
Because what am I going to do?
I can't sing.
I'm just going to
play my ukulele?
I remember being so intimidated
by standing up in
front of an audience just with
my ukulele and playing.
In fact, some of my early
performances, I would go on
stage and just be like,
(MUMBLING) uh, oh, this song
is called "Sunshine
of Your Love."
[MUSIC - "SUNSHINE
OF YOUR LOVE"]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: And I
would start playing.
But I was so afraid.
Because I just thought, oh, the
ukulele by itself, it just
sounds so empty.
And it doesn't have that full
sound that I'm used to hearing
when I go and listen
to a concert.
I want that big, big
sound, right?
But I couldn't get that
with this instrument.
But when I saw "Bill Cosby,
Himself," when I saw him-- and
I saw a man just come up on
stage in front of thousands of
people, sit in a chair
with a microphone.
And he could just connect
with every single
person in the room.
And I was watching this
on television.
And I still felt like
I was there.
I felt like every story he was
telling, he was looking right
at me and telling this.
Like I was sitting down in his
living room and he was just
sharing this amazing
story with me.
And I was so inspired by that.
Because then I realized,
you know what?
The instrument that we hold
is just an illusion.
Guitar players-- like if you
watch Jimi Hendrix, yeah, he's
playing the guitar.
But the guitar is just
an illusion.
His artistry, his music,
he's communicating--
it's his whole--
before you even hear
his guitar,
you're hearing his spirit.
He's communicating this thing.
Like one of the things that I
believe is all the music that
you play and you hear happens.
It's created and happens before
it even gets to your
instrument.
Before I play that chord,
I need to create
it inside of me.
I need to feel it and just
create it first.
And then, then I can
play that chord.
Or before I bend that note--
[PLAYING MUSIC, GUITAR-SOLO
STYLE]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: --I need to
create it inside of me, before
it even gets to the
instrument.
So I used to watch him.
And I used to watch
him all the time.
I watched that performance
over and over.
And he's just so natural.
And the title of that tour was
"Bill Cosby, Himself." And I
realized that that's
all you got to be.
It doesn't matter if you're
talking to one
person or 1,000 people.
The more you're comfortable with
who you are, if you can
just get up in front of--
and not be afraid
to make fun of yourself.
And not to have expectations
of the audience, I
think, is a big key.
And that's the cool thing about
being a ukulele player,
is that audiences have such low
expectations of me anyway.
So if I don't have any
expectations of my audience, I
can simply get up on stage
and just do my thing.
And I don't have to worry
about anything.
If someone laughs, if they stay,
then that's all a bonus.
So I was telling that story
because I was trying to relate
that to a song.
Yeah, yeah, so.
What song was I going
to play now?
I don't remember.
But anyway, that's kind
of where a lot of my
inspiration came from.
It's not so much about
playing the ukulele.
But it's just about
communicating with people.
And that's what all of you do.
Through Google, through YouTube,
you're providing a
vehicle for people to
communicate from one side of
our planet all the way
to the other side.
And it makes the planet
seem so much smaller.
It makes our world seem
so much smaller.
And I think that's
a great thing.
Because I grew up in
Hawaii, where we
live on a small island.
And everyone's so
community-minded.
We're always thinking about
the other person.
And we all see how we're related
and what I do affects
this other person.
What that person does affects
the other person.
And I think it's such a great
way to look at the world now,
is that we are all connected.
We're all connected.
And I think through music and
through what you do, I think
it's the perfect example.
Because to me, music is not just
a universal language, but
it's the language
of the universe.
And you're helping to
spread that language
all across the world.
And it's a beautiful thing.
So I'm going to play
one more song here.
And they've asked me to try to
play more original stuff just
because of copyright issues
and all of that.
But I did want to play this one
piece because this is the
reason I'm here.
And this is what started
it all for me.
And it was a simple four-minute
video clip that
happened to show up on
the internet one day.
And it was for a television show
that I had done in New
York called "Ukulele Disco."
And I think I told this
story the last time.
But since then, I've made some
changes to the song.
So I thought I'd
play it again.
But this is George Harrison's
"While My Guitar Gently
Weeps."
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: And it's
probably my favorite song to
play on the ukulele.
And I can't play this enough.
This is just so much fun.
But it's amazing, talking about
how to express yourself
through the instrument.
It's not just about the notes
that you're playing or the
chords that you're playing.
But it's everything.
It's just all the sounds
that you can create.
[PLAYING MUSIC]
[MUSIC - "WHILE MY GUITAR
GENTLY WEEPS"]
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Thank
you very much.
Thank you.
Whew, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: That
was awesome.
And I just wanted you to
know that was just
such a famous version.
That was how I was introduced
to your music.
And I just wanted to know if
you wanted to talk a little
bit about George Harrison.
I know that he was an ambassador
of the ukulele.
George was famous for riding
around in a car full of them
and passing them out and wanting
to literally get
together and play with
everyone he went.
If you want to talk a little
bit about that?
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Yeah, George
Harrison was one of my heroes.
He just adored this
instrument.
He had 100 times more ukuleles
than I have.
But the cool thing--
though I never got
to meet him.
I wish I did.
I met his wife, Olivia Harrison,
a few times.
She actually came to a
couple of my shows.
And that was pretty amazing,
being able to speak with her
and talk with her.
And she kept telling me, oh, I
wish George was still alive
today because he just loved
this instrument so much.
And he really believed that this
instrument had so much
potential to reach beyond.
To me--
and I can't say exactly-- but
I think George Harrison
probably felt the same way.
I think that the ukulele
is very special.
It's different from other
instruments because people
aren't afraid of this
instrument.
They're not intimidated by it.
Because a lot of people don't
even think of it as a real
instrument.
They think it's a toy, right?
And I embrace that.
I love that.
Because I think every
instrument should--
people should feel like that
about every instrument.
The piano-- oh, the
piano, I can do--
oh, yeah, yeah-- or the violin
or whatever it is.
Because if you're afraid of an
instrument, then you're never
going to want to pick it up.
You'll be too intimidated.
Or in your mind, you think
it's too hard.
But with the ukulele--
I mean, my grandmother just
started playing the ukulele.
And now, she's jamming
with her girlfriends.
And they're singing, you are
my sunshine, my only sun--
they're singing songs
like that.
But like I said earlier, I
believe that music is not just
the universal language,
but it's the
language of the universe.
And there's something amazing
that happens when you have the
ability to speak
that language.
When you can pick up an
instrument and just do this--
[STRUMS CHORDS]
and you know that I can
do this, it just
makes you feel so good.
I tell you, it's like
an entire yoga
session in one strum.
I mean, you can play one chord
over and over and over.
And there's just something
about that.
It just brings you
back to center.
It zeroes you out.
And George Harrison loved that
about this instrument.
He loved turning
people onto it.
And loved showing people
how easy it is to play.
Because you get that instant
gratification.
The moment you pick it up, you
can just take one finger and
just put it right there,
and be like, wow.
[STRUMMING CHORDS - "MARY
HAD A LITTLE LAMB"]
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Like,
oh my gosh.
If I had to do that on a
trumpet, it would take me like
two months before I could
even get a decent sound.
Or a violin, it takes you two
months before you can even
hold the bow without cramping.
So it's that instant
gratification.
And I think that when people
pick it up for the first time
and they play it, they're like,
wow, I can do this.
I can make music.
And to me, that's the joy
that music should bring.
That joy, everyone should feel
that joy when they're playing
the piano for the first time,
when they're playing the
violin for the first time.
When they're playing the
saxophone for the first time,
when they're playing the guitar
for the first time.
If everyone could feel that joy,
I think there would be a
lot more people playing
instruments.
AUDIENCE: Well, I had a question
for you, Jake.
I was at the screening
of the documentary.
Congratulations on that.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Oh,
thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: That was
pretty amazing.
One thing that really came
through in the documentary is
how much of a family affair
your music is.
And so I wanted to see if you
could tell us a little bit
more about that.
And maybe let us know if that
Shimabukuro family concert at
that screening is going
to be available later.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Oh, well, the
documentary that Cliff's
talking about is, I just
recently did my first
full-length documentary
with PBS.
And we've been shooting it for
a little over two years now.
And we just wrapped it up
last week Wednesday.
And it's going to
be premiering at
some of the film festivals.
And it's also going to broadcast
on PBS national TV
sometime early next year.
So I'm very excited
about this.
Because it was pretty amazing
just for me to kind of sit--
and I don't like to see myself
on television or anything.
But just being able to sit there
and see the last like 30
years of my life just
kind of go by.
And it really took me back to
why I fell in love with this
instrument, how I got into it.
I started playing at
the age of four.
And I got into it because
my mom played.
She played.
And the first thing she taught
me was my C chord.
And I would just do
this all day.
And I loved it.
I did that every day.
I'd come home from school,
pick up my
ukulele, and just play.
And my mom loved it.
My family, they love music.
And I also have a younger
brother who plays, too.
And when we were kids, that's
what we'd do together.
We'd always play the
ukulele together.
My brother was really
good at sports.
And I mean, he was very
well rounded.
Like for me, the only thing I
could do was play the ukulele.
Like till this day, I can't
dribble and do a layup.
I mean, I'm horrible.
But there was something about
music that I could just sit
down for hours at a time and
just play and discover new
chords and new sounds.
So that really kept our
family together.
My dad played a little
bit of guitar.
But they weren't professional
musicians or anything.
But there was always music
playing in the house.
So I think in the documentary,
it kind of
talks about my parents.
They divorced and all that.
And so music kind
of became my--
because my mom was
my first teacher.
And she would spend a lot of
time, when I was a kid,
teaching me.
So I think once my parents got
the divorce and my mom had to
work all the time--
my brother and I, we're
five years apart.
So I would always stay home.
And I would always have
to watch him.
I always felt like he was more
like my son than my brother.
And so I think playing the
ukulele for me was--
in my mind, now looking
back at everything--
was kind of like that was me
trying to make up for those
lost times of spending with
my mom or my family.
It kind of took me back.
So I guess that's where my
passion, I guess, comes from
for this instrument.
And even though I'm away from
home a lot of times, having
the ukulele with me and being
able to play and share all of
these things, I think I
always feel like I'm
right back with them.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
if you had any plans or
expectations on teaching
your baby the ukulele.
And if so, at what age you're
planning on introducing it?
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Well, I have
no expectations right now.
I mean, I want him to do
whatever he wants to do.
But I definitely want
him to have music.
And it's funny because on my
new album, the song that I
wrote for him is called
"Gentlemandolin." And it's the
third song on the album.
And it's funny because recently,
while I was on tour,
my wife discovered that when
he's crying, if she puts the
CD on, he immediately stops.
And she says, it's amazing.
So she said, she
puts the CD on.
And as soon as she puts it on,
the first song starts.
And she said he just kind
of stops and he
just kind of listens.
And he becomes super mellow.
Then the second song comes on.
And it's actually a cover of
Adele's "Rolling in the Deep,"
and he listens through that.
And then she said the third song
comes on, which is the
song I wrote for him.
As soon as that song starts,
he starts, [WAILING]
like starts crying.
She says it's unbelievable--
every single time.
She said, he just doesn't
like that song.
So I don't know.
But anyways, so I probably
won't be
teaching him that song.
Yeah, but I definitely want
to get him into music.
Yeah, for sure.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: You were talking
a little earlier about just
kind of growing up with
a ukulele and
playing it for so long.
But it's an instrument I've
heard my entire life.
And I've never heard it
played the way you do,
until you came along.
So what happened in your life
when you were playing?
When did it start transpiring,
you started learning new
things and started bringing
things out of the instrument
that other people didn't see?
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: I think for
me I started out playing all
traditional Hawaiian music.
But then I think there came a
time, I think when I was just
in my early teenage years,
when I saw my
first Van Halen concert.
And it wasn't so much that I
wanted to play all those fancy
guitar riffs or anything
like that.
But it was more about
the energy.
When I see rock bands play,
I admire their energy.
It's not necessarily I want to
play that kind of music or I
want to play that song
or anything.
But I want to play with
that kind of energy.
And so whether I'm playing
a Hawaiian tune or a jazz
standard or a classical piece or
a pop tune, or even if I'm
covering a rock song, I
want to play with that
energy all the time.
And it's not always the physical
kind of energy or the
kind of energy that you can see
visually, like just the
running and jumping on stage,
jumping around and all that.
I mean, that's great too.
I like that, when I'm like--
[PLAYING MUSIC]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: I like to kind
of move with the music.
But it's also the other kind
of energy, the energy that
comes from within, that focus,
that mental focus.
I'm always talking about like
when I would do workshops.
And I would talk with kids and
performers about when you're
playing your instrument, it
doesn't matter what instrument
you're playing.
Like when I'm playing the
ukulele and I'm going to play
a chord, it's not just
the mechanics.
It's not just about my finger
and my hand, my fingers
holding down the right strings
and my hand just doing this.
It's not about that.
But there's so much that
happens before
and after the stroke.
So there's a lot
of preparation.
And I always kind of compare
it to a pitcher.
You know, when you watch a
really good baseball pitcher,
the windup--
I mean everything, the follow
through, the focus, the
visualizing of how the ball
is going to curve or drop.
All of that is so important.
Like even when you're
playing the ukulele,
that's what I'm thinking.
Before even I even
hit the strings--
you can't really tell, but my
toes curl up in my shoes.
And I can feel all that energy
in my ankles and the balls of
my feet, to my knees,
to my hips.
Everything that comes down, up
my back, through my shoulders.
And when I make contact with
the string, it's all that
energy directed this way.
And it's not just the
physical energy.
But it's all my mental
focus, my thoughts.
Everything is going in that
direction, going with the
music, playing with that kind
of conviction, my spirit.
Everything that I have, that
I have control of, I try to
bring that into every stroke,
into every strum.
And it's not just the
hard-hitting stuff.
It's the soft stuff, too.
It's like when you play--
[PLAYING MUSIC, DELICATELY]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: I want
to just bring that--
bring every note out.
And it's still that
follow-through, that same
conviction, that same energy
that I would if I were playing
like a rock tune and a classical
piece or a ballad.
It's a different
kind of energy.
But it's still that same
intensity, with that same
conviction, that you want to
put into every little note,
every little movement.
Everything that you do needs to
be somehow connected to the
music, whether it's just a
simple tapping of the foot or
tapping of the toes.
Or if it's a little twitch
in the face.
Like you watch guitar players
sometimes and they do these
uncontrollable facial
expressions.
They're just like--
and it's because all of that
movement, everything that's
happening, is somehow connected
with the sound or an
idea or a concept that they're
trying to convey emotionally.
And I don't remember what the
question was anymore.
But I hope I answered it.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
You did answer it.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Oh, OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Right here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for playing for us today.
I have a question about if
there's anything particular
about your instrument that
you'd like to talk about.
How did you end up
choosing this
particular ukulele to play?
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Oh, yeah.
Well, this is an instrument,
a ukulele made by a family
called the Kamaka family.
And they're made right
in Hawaii.
And they were the first family
to start manufacturing
ukuleles in the world.
I think they're going on four
generations of ukulele
makers right now.
And it's just a family
business.
And they were the first
Hawaiians to learn how to
build these instruments from the
Portuguese immigrants that
came over to the Islands to work
in the plantation fields.
So they were the ones who really
started to build the
first ukuleles.
And it's quite extraordinary.
Because they've been building
ukuleles for
almost 100 years now.
And when I was a kid--
in Hawaii, everybody knows
Kamaka Ukulele.
When I was growing
up, my dream was
to have this ukulele.
They call this a tenor-size
instrument.
It's a tenor, four-string
Kamaka.
And it was my dream to have the
instrument because in my
eyes, it was like the Excalibur
of instruments.
But they're very expensive.
So when I was a kid, there
was no way I could afford
something like this.
And so now that I get to play
this instrument every day, I
just feel so honored.
Because there's just so much
history and so much experience
and knowledge that goes into
every single one of their
instruments.
So to actually be able to play
and to use one, to travel
with, and to create music with,
to write music with, I
just feel like all of that
history comes with
everything that I do.
So yeah, that's what it is.
It's a Kamaka.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Hi.
AUDIENCE: It's always such an
inspiration to see you perform.
And two years ago, when I last
saw you, I was so inspired
that I went and I brought
an ukulele.
Because I used to play the
Venezuelan four-string cautro.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO:
Oh, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: It's pretty much
the same thing, right?
So I took it and I went
to the guitar store.
I just went right from--
where you were, I went right
to the guitar store.
I bought this little
four-string
thing, took it home.
And there I am with my little
three chords, you know,
chinka, chinka, chinka, chinka,
chinka, chinka,
chinka, chinka.
Anyway, my then 13-year-old
wanders up, like, hey, Mom,
what's that?
I never saw it again.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Wow.
AUDIENCE: She goes off to
school every day with a
fiberglass ukulele slung
across her back.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Nice.
AUDIENCE: So I just wanted to
let you know that you had that
kind of impact.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Aw,
thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: That's
beautiful.
One of the coolest things
for me is seeing--
like when I tour now and do
shows, we see a lot of kids,
young kids, come to
the show now.
And they don't look like
ukulele players.
They come with the
But they have their fingernails
all painted black.
They have spiky hair,
piercings.
And they just think the ukulele
is the coolest thing.
They'll come up and they'll be
like, oh, yeah, I used to play
heavy metal guitar.
And then I saw you play
"Why My Guitar
Gently Weeps" on YouTube.
And I threw my guitar away
and I bought a ukulele.
And this is all I play now.
And It's just the most
incredible thing.
Because 10 years ago, or
even I don't know--
maybe not even 10 years ago,
it was always the opposite.
People would start
on the ukulele.
And then after that, once they
can play it pretty good, then
they want to put it away and
move on to a guitar.
Because their goal is to play
the guitar and to use a
ukulele as a stepping stool
to get to the guitar.
But now it's really cool that
people that have been playing
the guitar want to put
their guitars away
and pick up the ukulele.
So it's great.
[? AUDIENCE: Guitar players ?]
are [INAUDIBLE].
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the
amazing performance.
So I just have a question--
have you ever thought about
giving up becoming a musician
like that then?
When you were frustrated, and
how you get over that.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Oh, no.
The thought never crossed my
mind that I would ever want to
give up playing.
But to be honest, when
I was a kid--
or even up until 10 years ago,
15 years ago, I had no idea
that I was going to be a touring
musician or even or I
could do this all the time.
I knew that I would always play
this instrument for the
rest of my life because
it's my passion.
But I thought it would just
be like coffee shops.
When l was just out of high
school, I used to play at a
lot of weddings and graduation
parties and birthday parties
and family functions.
But never in my wildest dreams
did I ever think I'd be doing
what I'm doing today.
So it never crossed my mind
that I'm going to
ever give this up.
But as things started to evolve
and a career started to
shape up for me, through the
internet and all that, and now
I'm touring.
Like now, in this next
two months, we're
touring through 40 cities.
And we got a whole tour bus now
and a seven-man crew, with
a sound and lighting guy.
And I never imagined
any of that.
It's just incredible.
When I was growing up, I thought
I was going to be a
school teacher.
I thought I was going to go into
education because I love
working with kids.
And then I thought, the ukulele
is the perfect way to
connect with kids.
So I thought in my classes,
in the lessons, I
could always use this.
So I would always have it.
But it's been real
challenging.
There have been times, like when
I first started touring,
there were a lot
of challenges.
But you kind of get
through them.
You work through them.
Like I say, when I first started
performing, I couldn't
look at everyone and play.
I was so nervous.
I'd be so afraid to talk.
And it's hard.
But you love it.
You love it so much.
And you always want to
figure out, how can
I improve on this?
How can I make this better?
Because I realized that I can
practice all I want in my
room, just by myself.
But it doesn't give me that
same satisfaction.
Because to me, again, music is
all about communicating.
It's about making a connection
with people.
And once I started learning
how to connect with people
through this instrument, oh, my
gosh, it was just a rush.
Now when I perform at a venue
and there are moments where
I'd be playing.
And you'd get to a real
sensitive part and you play
that one chord.
[STRUMS CHORD]
And you can just almost feel
the entire audience just
breathing with you and just
taking it all in and just
waiting for that last
note to fade away.
And then even after you can't
hear it anymore, it's just
silence, silence, silence,
silence.
And then everyone
starts clapping.
And it's those moments that
it's such a rush.
Because you just feel like
everyone is experiencing the
same thing.
And I guess the only way I can
think about it's like for
surfers when they catch
that perfect wave.
And they're just on that wave
and just nothing else matters.
You're just on that wave.
Or when I'm on stage and I'm
playing, it's like nothing
else matters.
I'm just having, really
literally, having
the time of my life.
And so for me, it's--
yeah, there are challenges.
But a lot of it is just pressure
that I put on myself.
I'm a bit of a perfectionist
in some ways.
And I want to keep
learning and keep
discovering new things.
So sometimes you go through
these periods where you're
just at a plateau.
And you're like, when's that
next idea going to come?
Or when's that next concept
going to come?
But yeah, you find ways to--
but then when you find
it, then it's like,
oh, my gosh, yes.
That's amazing.
And it carries you.
That inspiration, that
excitement carries you through
the next one.
Thank you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I guess I can't get enough of
hearing about "While My Guitar
Gently Weeps," which
was always one
of my favorite songs.
And it's the reason I
know who you are.
Because a close friend of mine
said, oh, you've got to listen
to this guy.
Here he is on YouTube.
His name's Jake something.
And your version of it
just blew me away.
It was absolutely--
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --gorgeous.
And especially a song that I
care so much about, to hear
someone else do it.
It was so beautiful it
moved me to tears.
And I actually made
it my ringtone--
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Oh, no way.
AUDIENCE: --like a week
before you came to
Google the first time.
And then I saw you the first
time and had a chance to talk
to you and ask you if you'd
ever met George Harrison.
And I forgot to tell you that
I'd actually just made it my
ringtone, even before you'd even
come to Google, copyright
issues not withstanding.
But I just wanted to ask you,
what made you put that song up
on YouTube?
Was that also one of your
favorite songs?
Or was it just by chance?
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Well, you
know, to be honest, till this
day, I don't know who put
it up on YouTube.
And I said this the
last time to you.
I'm just being totally honest
and sincere because this was
seven years ago.
So I didn't know what YouTube
was back then.
I'm not very internet savvy.
But I think YouTube just
kind of started
around that time, too.
So it wasn't that famous yet.
Not too many people
knew about it.
I was doing some email.
But I wasn't really active
on the websites and
internet and all that.
So what happened was I
just did this thing
for a local TV show.
And that's what they did
the interview for.
They videotaped me doing that
and then it aired on TV.
And it was just a small
little local network,
and that was it.
And then I went back
home to Hawaii.
And about two months later,
I had a lot of
friends that were here--
in Hawaii, we call this
the mainland--
so I had a lot of friends on the
mainland going to school.
And they started calling me
or sending me emails.
And they were like hey, there's
this video clip that's
going around our campus
of you playing.
And I was like, what are
you talking about?
So they sent me the link.
And at that time, it was still
that concept of emailing a
video or a video link
to somebody was
kind of like, what?
You're going to email
me a video?
What are you talking about?
Because it was just kind
of starting out.
So they emailed me this link.
And I clicked on it.
And it took me right to
the YouTube video.
And there it was.
And I just was like,
I don't understand.
What am I looking at?
And already it had almost
2 million views already.
And I couldn't believe it.
And there wasn't a term
for it back then.
There wasn't even such thing
as a viral video yet.
We didn't even know
what to call it.
It was just happening.
And it was shortly after that
the numbers just started
growing and growing
and growing.
And there were multiple
videos.
So there was one that didn't
even have my name.
It just said "While My Guitar
Gently Weeps" and it was that
same video.
Then there was one that
was like, Crazy
Asian Ukulele Player.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: So
there were eight or
nine different videos.
And all of them had like
over a million views.
But none of them had
my name yet.
So it wasn't until, I think, a
few months after that, that
finally there was a video
that had my name on it.
It was Jake Shimabukuro,
whatever.
And then that video just started
growing and growing
and growing.
And so all the other ones
just slowly disappeared.
I think there's still a couple
other ones out there.
But the main one right
now that was left--
I know when it first just had
my name on it, it was like
something like 30,000 views.
And that was maybe four years
ago or something.
But then that one, even from
four years ago, that one grew
to over 10 million now.
And it's amazing how it's
still just growing.
And so people are still
discovering this video for the
first time.
So it's been quite
extraordinary.
And that video changed
my life.
I wish I knew who the first
person was that put it on,
because, yeah--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Yeah, yeah,
that's what I tell people.
I think George Harrison up there
had something to do it.
But yeah, really, it
changed my life.
And from that, I started getting
calls from other
artists to come and open for
them-- oh, take care--
to tour with them and open for
them or record with them.
And it's been totally
extraordinary.
So, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So now, Jake--
hey, Jake.
So now you know why it took so
long for them to attach your
name to the video.
Because it took them that
long to learn how to
spell your last name.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO:
Yeah, I know.
No, it's so true, so true.
AUDIENCE: All right, so I
have a quick question.
I'll give you a heads
up, a little
bit of a set-up question.
But tell me a little bit about
the work that you did with
Alan Parsons.
So obviously, he's a very
well-known, Grammy-nominated
producer and engineer.
But you yourself, as a musician
for a long time, have
worked with a lot of producers
and engineers.
What made him different?
What did he do differently, like
radically different than
the masses of audio engineers
that are out there?
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Well, one of
the coolest things about Alan,
I mean, from day one, just being
in the recording studio
with him, was--
the first thing I noticed was
the way he miked my ukulele,
the way he recorded
my ukulele.
Every recording engineer I've
ever worked with, there was
always at least one microphone
in front of my instrument.
A lot of times if they record in
stereo, they would have one
here and then one here.
Because that's how they record
guitars, in stereo like that.
I've done mid-side miking where
you have one mic in the
middle, like kind of
a stereo spread.
And then you have one
across the top.
I've been in situations where
they would surround me with
microphones, put microphones
all over me, or put two
microphones right here and then
put two in the back of
the room or behind me.
But this was the first time that
someone told me, OK, just
stand right here.
He got one microphone.
He put it here under the
neck of my ukulele.
And he put another one right
here, above my right shoulder.
And I was like, are you sure
this is going to work?
And so he's like, yeah, yeah,
just play, and I'll make some
adjustments.
So I started playing.
And he just kind of tweaked it
a little bit, just moved, but
kept it right there.
And then he kind of tweaked
this one like that.
And then he's like, all right,
yeah, just play something.
So I just started--
I punched into a song.
And I played it.
And then he said, OK, come
in and tell me if
you like the sound.
So I walked into the
control room.
He played it back.
And I couldn't believe
what I was hearing.
It was the sound of my
instrument the way that I
always hear it, the way
that I hear it.
Because I've always just
accepted that every time I
record, my studio sound, what I
can get on a record, is just
different from my live sound
or what I hear when I'm
practicing.
But it was the first time I
walked into that room and he
played it back.
And I was stunned because
I was like, oh, my gosh.
I feel like I'm playing my
instrument right now.
That's how it felt.
And so I asked him about that.
I said, Alan, what made you
decide to record the
ukulele this way?
And he said he wanted to
record it in stereo.
So he wanted it at least two
microphones, so he could get a
right and a left channel.
But what he said was when he
records guitars that way, you
usually put one here and
then one up here,
because a guitar is longer.
So you can get a wider stereo
spread that way.
But he thought that because the
ukulele is shorter, if you
were to put one mic here at the
body and one mic here at
the neck, because the ukulele is
so tiny, the mics are going
to pick up pretty much
the same sound.
So you're not going to get
that much of a stereo
difference.
The right and the left are going
to sound very similar.
So he thought he could get a
wider stereo spread if he put
one mic down here to pick up
closer to the first string,
and one mic up here, which would
pick up closer to the
fourth string.
And that way he can keep the
mics further apart, yet they'd
be the same distance
to the instrument.
It sounds simple, but it was
just the most brilliant thing
that I had ever heard.
And I was like, wow, so when
you listen to the album,
you're thinking--
this great stereo spread that
you're hearing, I mean, it's
like you're in the middle
of the instrument.
But it's not so much
right and left, but
it's more up and down.
So it's like he took that up
and down sound and just
flipped it over so you get
your right and your left.
And so that, for me,
was like, wow.
That was amazing.
And then other things-- like
because Alan comes from that
old school way of recording,
he wanted to
do everything live.
So we have a 29-piece
orchestra on a
few of these tracks.
And everything was
recorded live.
There are absolutely
no overdubs.
So we went into this
huge studio.
We had the 29-piece
orchestra there.
And then I was in the same
room with the orchestra.
The only thing that divided
me from the
orchestra was a glass door.
And we all watched the same
conductor up there.
And we all played.
And there's something amazing
that happens when you do that,
when you play live.
Because all the musicians are
listening to each other and
playing off of each other.
So there are a lot of
spontaneous things that just
happen, that wouldn't have
happened if we just played all
our parts separately.
Because we would have just been
reading the music and
just played our parts.
But because we were playing it
together, it's that whole
synergy effect.
We're all creating something
together.
We're all in the room together,
making this.
And it was really beautiful.
That song "Missing Three" that
I played for you, it's a
three-string song.
I was so proud of it because I
was like, oh, you only play it
with three strings.
And I sent that.
That was the first demo
that I'd sent to Alan.
And he listened to it.
I didn't tell him
the story yet.
I just sent him the song.
And he listened to it.
And he was like, oh, gosh,
that's beautiful.
And he told me, I can just hear
an entire string section
playing with you on that.
And so it was ironic.
Because it's a song that I
wrote it with just three
strings, but now there's
a 29-piece orchestra.
So there's over 100 strings
on the song now.
But still, he was very careful
about making sure that the
ukulele was here and
everything else
played around it.
He didn't want anything
to bury the ukulele.
And it was just amazing
working with him.
He mixed the entire record
in two days.
He would just get up there.
And you know, all the faders,
and he just--
whst, whst, whst.
And in like 20 seconds, he'd
have a perfect mix of a
29-piece orchestra with me.
And he would just sit
back and listen.
He would go, maybe the horns
need to come down a little bit
right here.
And then he would turn
around and be
like, what do you think?
I was just like, it
all sounds great.
Yeah, let's go.
It was really inspiring
working with him.
MALE SPEAKER: I think this
is our last question.
AUDIENCE: It is.
And so I was wondering-- in
each of your albums, your
style changes, your
style evolves.
So what about "Grand Ukulele"
are you most proud of in the
evolution of your style?
And where do you see it
going in the future?
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: There were a
lot of things on this record,
like just really
subtle things.
Like I was talking about, always
just looking for that
one thing to make
it different.
There were songs on this album
where I utilized techniques
that I never used before.
For example, there's this one
song called "Music Box," where
I do this thing where I keep my
thumb alternating between
the third and fourth string.
And then I play the entire song
or entire melody on the
first string.
[MUSIC - JAKE SHIMABUKURO,
"MUSIC BOX"]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: But there's
this one section in the song
where I play that melody
harmonically.
So while I'm keeping this going,
[ALTERNATING NOTES]
I play this melody.
[PLAYING MELODY]
I'm going to play
it for you here.
Just listen.
[MUSIC - "MUSIC BOX"]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: That section
right there for me was like, I
had never done anything
like that before.
So I thought that was cool.
There's another place-- and
you'll never notice it unless
I talk about it.
But I did a version of "Fields
of Gold." And there's this one
section in there where
I take the melody--
[MUSIC - "FIELDS OF GOLD"]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: (SINGING
ALONG) Da, da, da, dah, dah.
So there's this one section
where I play that harmonically
as well, again.
But what I do is I utilize this
technique where instead
just playing the harmonics by
itself, I would fret a string
to almost mimic a bass note.
So I have this over
the F chord.
What I'm doing is I'm
holding the F root.
But as I play that F root, I'm
also going to use my other
fingers to play the harmonics
of the other strings
together, like this.
So I can get this kind of
harmony, which is something
you don't hear.
Like ukulele players wouldn't
know, how do you get that F
Major 7 sound with harmonics?
So when I play that
part, it's like--
[MUSIC - "FIELDS OF GOLD"]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: See.
So for me that was another--
I'd never done anything,
this kind of stuff.
[PLAYING MUSIC]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: That kind
of sound, it's very--
Jaco Pastorius, one of my
favorite bass players, would
do things like that where
he would kind of
roll the bass around.
And he would fret these amazing
harmonics and just get
these incredible--
[PLAYING MUSIC]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: I don't
if you can hear that.
[PLAYING MUSIC]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO:
So hear that?
[PLAYING MUSIC]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: So the flat
7 there, you would never
usually hear that
on the ukulele.
But you are able to--
[PLAYING MUSIC]
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Yeah,
yeah, so, yeah.
So those kinds of things, that's
the kind of stuff that
really keeps me going.
And most people won't hear
it or won't notice it.
But for me it's like, oh yeah,
that makes the entire
arrangement for me, or
the entire song.
I had a great time working
on this record.
I really feel like Alan really
pushed me in the studio.
And so it was great.
Because that's what you want
from a producer, who knows how
to push, but not overpush, where
you get discouraged.
And it was such a great
experience.
He brought in just some amazing
musicians, like Kip
Winger, from the band Winger.
He did some of the orchestral
arrangements.
We had Simon Phillips,
one of my favorite
drummers, from Toto.
He played on the record.
Randy Tico, a phenomenal
bass player.
It was just really
inspiring for me.
Because Alan--
he's worked with everyone
from the Beatles to--
even with his Alan Parsons
Project and all that, Pink
Floyd, his vision is so grand.
He has so much experience.
For me, a lot of times,
my vision only
comes with what I can--
I only see what I can
do with the ukulele.
But I don't think beyond that.
Whereas Alan Parsons comes from
that school where he's
worked with so many
orchestras.
He's worked with so
many arrangers.
He's worked with so many
rhythm sections.
And he's recorded so many
different kinds of
instruments.
And he knows all about
microphones and preamps.
And he knows how to get
this kind of sound.
Or if I'm trying to express
something, he knows the best
way to capture that so that it
translates when you listen to
it on a record.
If I'm going for that real
sensitive touch, he knows how
to pick it up with a mic and
using the right microphone
with the right preamp and
placing it in the right spot,
so that we can get that sound.
Or even if I'm playing with the
orchestra, how to EQ the
strings or how to EQ the horns
or the woodwinds so that the
frequencies don't overpower the
ukulele and the ukulele
can still be over.
Because a lot of times, it's
not just a volume issue.
But it's a panning issue, like
where you place it in the mix,
in the stereo mix.
And then also how you EQ it,
so that you EQ it just in a
way so that it--
I don't really understand
all this kind of stuff.
But I have very limited
understanding.
I mean, it's a whole science.
And it's amazing.
His ears are just incredible.
We'd be mixing the song.
We'd be recording something.
And he'd be in the room.
And then we'll be listening
on the playback.
And we'd be just listening.
And like, oh, yeah, OK, that
sounded all right.
And we're listening.
And then the phone would ring.
And Alan would be like,
oh, OK, well, I
got to get the phone.
And so he'll kind of step out.
And he'll be on the phone
outside of the studio.
All of a sudden, he'll
come running back in.
What was that?
Go back, go back, go back
like 20 seconds.
It's amazing.
He just hears everything.
And it was just extraordinary
to work with
him and to see someone--
because when he's in the studio,
he's just like a
little kid.
He loves it.
He's so passionate
about recording.
And so to work with
someone like
that was really inspiring.
Because for me, I'm passionate
about this.
And then to work with him, who's
passionate about doing
all the other stuff, I think it
was a great collaboration.
And it was one of the
greatest recording
experiences of my life.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, great.
Thanks so much for
coming here.
And we look forward to picking
up the conversation when you
come back here.
JAKE SHIMABUKURO: Yeah,
oh, thanks.
Great.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you.
[MUSIC - JAKE SHIMABUKURO,
"WHILE MY
GUITAR GENTLY WEEPS"]